>>Katie: Having an Instructional
Coach has been the biggest help
that I could have had this year.
Because she not only helps me with
lesson plans, but she helps me think
through why I'm going to teach that way.
>>Pam: Our Instructional Coaches
work very closely with teachers
across the School Division
to help them really figure
out what we call our Seven
Pathways to Learning.
Whether it's Make-a-Work, or whether
it's giving kids the opportunity
to have choice in their work.
Our coaches really are a lynchpin in
the work that we do across the system.
>>Debora: Instructional Coaches
connecting teachers from one school
to another is very important
because we feel
like that's how innovative
practices spread.
We have 24 Instructional Coaches,
but no one coach is at one building.
Every building has at
least three coaches.
Every coach has at least three schools.
>>Lisa: Trish has been
with us for four years.
And Trish is an Instructional
Coach for the Division.
She's actually works in three schools.
Woodbrook is just one of her schools.
>>Trish: So if I'm learning from
these twelve teachers at this school,
I take all of that learning with
me to the other two schools.
When I get together with the
coaches, I'm able to share.
>>Trish: So I just want to
show you the first activity
on this Fractions Number Chart
resource is a skip counting activity.
>>Katie: That's what Karen was talking
to me about at recess the other day.
>>Trish: Okay!
>>Debora: Our teachers might have
a Project Based Learning Unit
that they're doing and they want
to bring more technology in,
and they want to bring some
different instructional strategies.
And they would approach a coach,
and talk a little bit about that.
>>Trish: Kate came to me and said,
"I'd love to do a Project Based
Unit coming up on Life Processes."
>>Katie: The Project Based Learning Unit
that Trish Moya and I have been working
on is a unit on plant
and animal life cycles.
Project Based Learning
is pretty new for me,
so Trish brings a whole nother
level of expertise to the board.
>>Trish: And so what will you
be looking for on your notes?
>>Katie: I'll be looking for
them to develop vocabulary.
>>Trish: Okay!
>>Katie: In the plant or animal
that they're researching.
>>Trish: Excellent!
Is there anything from the
Critical Thinking Rubric
that you might be able to use then?
>>Katie: I can use, "Feedback from my
friends and teacher to improve my work."
>>Trish: It always comes
back to the teacher getting
to tell you what they need.
So that's always where I begin.
>>Tony: So whether it comes to them
modeling instructional lesson plans
to help the teachers see what it
might look like, or moving into more
of an observation role,
where the teacher's trying it
out and looking for feedback.
Either way, the whole process is based
on what the teacher's looking for.
>>Katie: Let's get to it.
Step 1, gather all your materials.
>>Katie: I'm really excited about
the unit, because the kids are going
to be doing it in such an authentic way.
They're going to be creating videos,
and doing their own research.
They're going to be posting their
own things on a blog or a website.
Just something that they'll
always remember.
Working with Trish I learned that
kids really can drive their learning.
>>Student: We were learning
about the life cycle of animals.
>>Student: I'm learning about squirrels.
And I picked squirrels because
I actually like squirrels.
>>Student: And I learned that
there's many different cats.
>>Trish: And they were so excited
about what they had learned.
Did you notice that everybody
was up on their knees.
>>Katie: They were all
up on their knees!
>>Trish: Nobody was sitting down.
They were all like, "I want to share!
I want to share!"
That was great.
>>Katie: That was the cool part.
>>Tony: How these coaches then become a
conduit for those ideas and those values
to move from classroom to
classroom, from school to school,
that permeate the entire District,
is a really powerful thing.
And that it comes from
the teacher's goals,
and the teacher-centered approach really
does allow for the bottom-up growth
that you'd really hope
to be able to see.